[Musique]
c'est au jardin de l'état à saint denis
que l'association u d'art l'union
départementale des artistes de la
réunion ont organisé un concours de
peinture artistique à destination du
grand public vingt-cinq artistes ont
répondu présent c'est un concours
organisé par une association
s'appelle l'union des artistes
réunionnais ludin s'est ouvert à tous à
tout le monde participe et et désigner
des prix à la clé
et une contrainte fait du journal d'état
il faut déchirer sur place et les
sionistes qui a sur place la lidc décidé
le bassin qui en face du muséum
donc voilà en plein de couleurs
normalement
pastel acrylique ou peinture à l'huile
peintres amateurs ou professionnels ils
avaient tous l'obligation de dessiner le
jardin états dans leur propre au style
c'est ce que nous rappelle sabine
tyrrell présidente de bidart
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième jour du
concours de peinture en plein air du
genre d'ami les temps et il ya une peu
près 25 artistes qui sont dans le jardin
en train de peindre ce qu'ils voient et
c'est l'objet du concours justement donc
à peu près de dix ans - on réalise tous
les ans dans un lieu différent pour que
les artistes justement est l'occasion de
se renouveler de faire d'autres
paysages et de produits d'autres
tableaux
[Musique]